My opponent tonight
was President Trump's
White House
communications director.
Here's what you need to know.
He calls himself "the Mooch."
That's it.
That's all you need to know.
Anthony Scaramucci, everybody.
(cheering and applause)
Mooch, can I call you the Mooch?
-You can call me the Mooch.
-Mooch.
-Anything you want.
-I'm gonna call you the Mooch.
I want to talk leaks.
Last week,
White House aide Kelly Sadler
said of John McCain,
"It doesn't matter.
He's dying anyway."
That's rough.
I mean, that's obviously
an inappropriate thing to say.
It's, uh... You know, I think
she apologized in private,
and there was thoughts
about her apologizing in public.
I have no idea why she's not
apologizing in public,
but it would be a good idea
for her to do that.
-But-but I think...
-Yeah, so why...?
Yeah, why doesn't she come out
and apologize?
Well, I think the president has
had a long-standing feud
with, uh, the senator,
and I think, uh,
you know, there's been
a political feud there,
um, but, like, as I've said,
that he is an American patriot.
You don't have to agree with him
politically,
but the truth of the matter is,
we have to move past it,
and I think
you are catching wind
that The White House has got
a bunch of leakers in there.
That was a hit job
on Kelly Sadler.
Now raise your hand in this room
if you've never said anything
that you regret.
I know I have. I mean, one of
the things that I said got me...
Well, I think
a lot of it is on tape.
-One of the things...
-(laughter)
-Not a lot of it, thank God.
-There's some of it.
Thank God a lot of it isn't
on tape.
-Just a little bit
of it's on tape. -Sure, sure.
But the...
but the truth of the matter is,
you know, people do,
you know, so...
-People say things they regret.
-They say things they regret.
And so, hopefully, uh,
they won't fire Kelly.
She's great at her job.
She's been very loyal
to the president,
and she's not a leaker,
by the way, so...
-She's a classy person. I like
her. -Well, what's the issue
with these leaks
that are coming out right now?
It's a bad culture.
You know, you've got a group
of people in there
that really only care
about themselves.
They don't really care
about the president's agenda.
Um, they obviously
are all anonymous.
They do it surreptitiously.
It's a currency
with the journalists.
And so, uh,
they call up the journalists,
and they leak nefarious things
about each other.
I mean, the fact
that they were having
a conversation about leaking,
and Sarah Huckabee-- who I think
is an awesome professional--
says "Okay, I'm gonna
say something now,
and it's probably gonna get
leaked to the press" and then,
the exact words that she's
saying gets leaked to the press
is a sign of the rampant
dishonesty
that's in the system, and so...
-Or that she can see
into the future. -Yeah. Yeah.
(laughter)
Well, I hope she sees good
things for you and me, baby.
-Fingers crossed.
-Yeah, yeah.
Well, there's what the...
I'm feeling pretty good
about it, though.
-You like...? It feels good?
-Yeah. Yeah, no.
I like our rapport.
Well, thank you for... Yeah.
-Mooch, it's... feels comfy.
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, Jordy.
Go ahead.
The left is gonna push back, and
they're gonna say these leaks
that are coming out
of The White House--
they're emblematic
of a larger problem,
that they come from on high,
that people are upset
with the president. Is it...?
Do you point blame at, uh...
at what... the environment
-Donald Trump's created? John
Kelly? -So, I mean, a lot of...
a lot of these guys got-got
into The White House.
They were astonished
that the president won.
Some of them were frankly
booking for...
Who were a lot of these guys?
Who...?
-You know, it's-it's no...
-Come on.
-There's no... there's no...
-You like this rapport. Come on.
-Who are the guys?
-There's no... There's...
I got... I got to...
I got to be honest with you.
I-I would be very happy
to name them,
but I'd have to look at the
roster. I don't really remember,
uh, from six, eight, nine months
ago. That's the truth.
-Mooch! Mooch! -That's the
truth. -(audience groaning)
-Yeah.
-See, this is the problem.
-"I'd like to name them, but..."
-Nah.
I'm happy to name 'em,
but I just don't remember.
If you show me the roster,
I can pick out the leakers,
and you can put the two dots...
You don't have to be
Carrie Mathison from Homeland
to figure out
who's doing the leaking.
It's very easy to figure it out.
So, okay, let's say...
So, so,
but here's the problem, okay?
The-the culture got set up
that way by Reince Priebus.
He flooded the place
with "Never Trumpers."
with RNC people
who don't like the president.
And so now they're going after
the president
18 months into the presidency.
And so, it's nonsensical,
and those people
either need to stop, and there
needs to be a forcible change
in culture,
or they need to be removed.
-It's really that simple.
-But so, what do you do?
-If you... The Mooch is back
in The White House...
Well, if I had... if I had
12 days, I would have fired
-three or four more people...
-I was gonna say. Yeah.
And if I had 15 days,
I would have probably fired
another three
or four more people.
And then, I guarantee you that
the leaking would have stopped.
Uh, Mooch, I want to talk
about Sean Hannity.
Big news article came out today
that he's almost talking daily
-with President Trump.
-Mm-hmm.
Do you like that?
Do you like to see
finally Trump finding his people
in the media
so he can get his message out,
like the big Handster?
I thought he was talk...
I thought...
I thought he was talking to you
daily.
I'm, like, very disappointed.
-I'm checking in with him
every now and then. -You are?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Does he like that hairstyle?
-I mean, I don't know. That's...
-The man is obsessed with hair.
-You know that. -Yeah. I mean,
the way you're doing that,
though, is, like, fantastic.
It's, like, right up there
with The Donald.
It's really good.
-You-you... Really?
-I like it, yeah.
Wow.
(cheers and applause)
-That's how...
-If you put a little bit
of orange highlight in there,
-I think I can get you the comms
job, actually. -Really?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, that's...
Just a little bit of an orange
highlight, you'll be fantastic.
Look, I love Sean.
He's one of my best friends.
Uh, he's close to the president.
Uh, I don't think
it's any problem for him
to be talking to the president.
I think, you know and I know,
anything after 8:00 on these
networks are opinion pieces,
and so,
Sean's loaded with opinions.
I don't think they're looking
at him the same way
they're looking at other people
in the news organization.
Having said all that,
I think he's a very, very good
investigative journalist.
-I think he's uncovered a lot
of things as far... -But as...
But do you think that's...?
Is...?
You know,
the left is gonna push back.
They're gonna say like,
"He should be talking to experts
"and not journalists
with opinions,
"or opinion-makers
who say they're journalists..."
Well, I mean, listen,
you guys...
-"...or Sean Hannity."
-You guys... you don't don't...
(applause and cheering)
You guys don't like it.
I like Sean.
I think Sean's
a very accomplished guy.
He's a... he's been
a brilliant entrepreneur,
and, uh, he's close
to the president and his family.
I don't see the big deal.
-We're talking
about the old gang. -Yeah.
Do you ever get
to see the old gang--
the Stevie Two-Shorts,
The Self-Fellator, or, uh,
Rancid Penis--
you ever get to see him?
I mean, Stevie Two-Shorts--
why would you call him that--
-because of the self-fellating?
-Well, he self-felates,
but he's got...
He wears the two shirts.
I like the Sloppy Steve thing.
I think that's fun.
Adolph. I like calling him
"Adolph Bannon" once in a while.
-I think that's fun, but, yeah,
I mean, yeah. -Yeah.
-(audience groans loudly)
-Well, that's what he's like.
Well, that's what he's like. I
mean, just pay close attention.
-Do you talk to Donald Trump?
-Once in a while.
Yeah? Does he ever say anything
about me?
-Yeah, he loves your show.
Yeah, if you get... -Yeah?
Like, I said,
if you get me your résumé,
I think you and John Kelly would
get along unbelievably.
-Yeah.
Probably as well as John Kelly
and I got along.
-Mooch, tell me something
I already know. -Yeah.
Uh...
(laughter)
You're going to see, uh, peace
in the North Korean peninsula.
You're gonna see
full denuclearization
of the, uh, peninsula,
and you're probably going
to see a deal with the Iranians
at some point, a good deal
for the United States.
That I already knew.
Anthony Scaramucci.
The fight continues.